هذه كما تشاهدون على اليمين صوره للكرملين
مركز صناعه القرار في موسكو المحصن جدا
منذ الحقبه السوفيتي ضد كل الهجمات بما
فيها الهجمات بالصواريخ الاستراتيجيه لكنه
وكما يظهر في هذه الصوره على اليسار
استهدف لاول مره ربما في تاريخه بهجوم قال
انه بمسييرتين تم تعطيلهما عندما اقتربت
من موقعه الهجوم حدث بعد منتصف الليل
والمكان المستهدف
بالتحديد هو هنا حيث هذه القبه كما يظهروه
هو هذه القبه وهناك يوجد مكتب الرئيس
الروسي بوتين وحسب مدير مكتبنا فان المكان
المستهدفه بالمسيرتين قريب من مكان هبوط
المروحيه التي عاده ما يصل بها بوتين اما
اتجاه مسيرتين فمن منطقه كورنيش نهر موسكو
وهي منطقه قريبه من مصنع رزنه للاسلحه
ويظهر ان اجهزه الحمايه الفيدراليه
واستطعت رصد المسيرات واسقاطها نشير الى
ان الحادث وقع في المنطقه المطله على
الساحه الحمراء والمغلقه بشكل كامل وذلك
منذ 27 من ابريل استعدادا للعرض العسكري
بمناسبه عيد النصر في التاسع من مايوير
الحالي والذي اكل الكرملين انه سيجري في
موعده دون اي تعديل لكن هناك سؤال يتعلق
باين كان الرئيس بوتين عند وقوع الهجوم
عاده يكون للرئيس بوتين مكناني يداول
بينهما لكن نقل عن المتحدث الرسمي باسم
قوله ان بوتين كان موجودا هنا بمقر اقامته
بضواحي موسكو فينوفا اوغاريوفا ولم يصاب
باي اذى اذا هذا مقر اقامه الرئيس الروسي
في ضواحي موسكو
ولم يغير ايضا جدول اعماله وفقا والقصر
يقع غرب المدينه وهو مقر اقامه الرئيس
الروسي
الدعامي الفين هيئه الطوارئ الروسيه
بدورها اعلنت عن سقوط مسيره ايضا هنا في
كولومنا كولومنا وتقع في ضواحي موسكو
وتبعد نحو
110 كيلومترات تقريبا عن مبنى الكرملين عن
موسكو ومن اهم المعالم في المدينه او حصن
كولومنا لكن من غير الواضحين من اين اتت
المسيرات خاصه وان روسيا اتهمت كيف صراحه
بالمسؤوليه عن الهجوم فرضيه القدوم من
خارج من خارج الحدود وان طرحت لكنها تبقى
الى وفق محليلين ففي حال اعتبرنا ان هذه
الطائرات انطلقت من اقرب نقطه جغرافيه اي
من هذه النقطه من هنا من مقاطعه سومي وفي
اوكرانيا في شمال سومي فيجب ان تكون قادره
على التحليق لمسافه تصل الى نحو 600 كم
دون كشفها وهذا صعب وفق اكثر المحللين
ولكن بالنظر للانفجار طبيعه الانفجار
وحجمه رجح التحليلات مختلفه ان تكون
المسيرتان انطلقت من مكان قريب من الكريم
من مسافه قريبه يصعب على الرادارات رصدها
فمختلف الدفاعات الجويه موجوده ايضا
موجوده في اكثر من مكان
لرصد ومتابعه
وايضا حمايه الكرملين وفي العاصمه بدءا من
منظومه اس 400 المتطوره ومنظومه التي
تستهدف بدرجه اولى الصواريخ الصغيره الحجم
والمسيرات اذا من التداعيات اعلان وعمده
مدينه موسكو حضر اطلاق الطائره المسيره في
سمائها اعتبارا من اليوم بينما اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني مياده حاله التاهب الجوي في
عمومي